oh god i know let's just we'll talk
about a little bit right
so let me just let me just explore this
okay a little bit yeah i learned how to
do it
via pornography of course all right yeah
so i in the beginning like i would do
things that were like women were like
why did you do that like
right i'll spit in it that's fine i know
but it's like a
chogi oh you like mucus yeah like mucus
yeah yeah we used to call them choking
choking the back of the heart that
before that was
it right that sounds chunky yeah it's
chunky right
yeah yeah so i learned or you know i
don't wanna know don't do that with your
fingers again
yeah yeah so you learn you i learned and
i just realized that women don't really
like it you know i mean
yeah the porn way
yeah they do babe they do yeah
yeah you like no no no no no
we're not going to talk about what i
like i'll go okay we're just going to
assess your
hands this is just your skills yeah yeah
so you're good at that but you can i say
about your nose
yeah please i'm sure this is my i
am jealous of your nose mm-hmm yeah
you look very stoic to me yeah like for
instance right
if you were like the gran what's what's
the grand canyon where that president's
face
rush
if i was a president right and they were
gonna chisel my face
it would take three minutes right they
just
flatten it out check check the eyes and
then that's it
right with you they have to really carve
out the nose
right and get the future it would take
months and years maybe
to get it right maybe 10 years you have
a stoic face it's like
you know on a coin you would look good
we've
we've talked we've we've said i have
coin face yeah in our
youtube video that we did together oh
yeah you remember yeah i do
of course i remember yeah i look yeah i
look like i should be on a
coin yeah not american money yeah
um like something with a dictator like a
country for the dictator's money
also can i say this is when you a lot of
times i'll look at photos from the 1920s
or the 1800s and i say to myself
even if there were asians in this
scenario they would know i was from the
future
i just don't look like them yeah right i
just they would know
that like what alien creature is this
right
with you i feel like you can go to any
era
throughout the history of time yeah and
blend in what time is i agree
that's actually one of the sweetest
things anyone's ever said
i'm being real yeah and i know you are
yeah yeah yeah and i appreciate it so
that that so you should
you know really be appreciative if i
were to time travel i think i'd have a
all i'd got i'd have to do is just get
the clothing
and i'd blend in seamlessly but also
you could play back in the 20s right or
the 1800s
you could have been any job like you
could have been a lawyer
a doctor like you have that face right
yeah for me it's like
he either carries a rice from one you
know what i mean plant
plantation to another plantation right
or like
i'm in a pond right just like you know
raising koi fish yeah yeah but there's
not a lot of things i see you squatting
with like a
a bowl of rice yeah yeah you're a hole
in the ground yeah yeah yeah that's
basically yeah yeah you know
what you know i mean i would be doing
back then yeah
with you you your face and the way your
body is
and everything about you is very
timeless love it
feel good about it thank you so much i
don't see zits on your face
well i had to get accutane and they you
know and then when you do that they say
don't drink that's all i did
was drink so i really did some damage
yeah
but it was worth it because i want to
cast him i want to learn
because i said the documentary last
night and this is real and she probably
thinks
this is just a fad for me but it really
was scary
about social media and